hello babies it's episode 161 of
congratulations I'm drinking because I
felt like it man and remember no dense
[ __ ] it's Chris D'Elia here your host
of congratulations the podcast for
congratulations podcast or just
congratulations just merely
congratulations I'm chillin dude and
it's you know [ __ ] I had a I had a crazy
week dude a crazy good week
but before I get into that March 20th
let's do this I'm working out some new
material and I'm also trying to build my
hour I got a special thing coming up for
you guys in the fall at the end of
summer and it is gonna be bonkers dude
that's all I'm doing I'm teasing it
right now and I'm letting you know in
the fall doing something bonkers dude
it's gonna be diff dude it's gonna be
Steph
okay Steph it's gonna be different but
and it's and it's very cool and you guys
are gonna flip and so until then I'm
working on new material March 20th
through the 22nd I'll be in West Palm
Beach that big-ass improv they have over
there and the wood that's the whitest
place on earth is West Palm Beach that
always to me feels like The Truman Show
for real and it's and it's and it's and
it's nice and it's old old white people
so it's cool now a lot of times I see
old white people at my shows and I'm
like it's not my demo but maybe it is
Robinson Ville Mississip so if you want
to see me in a West Palm Beach Florida
get tickets now we just added two shows
so it's so big that improv it's gonna be
like 9,000 seats but it all sell out so
get it
and then in Robinson Ville Mississippi
I'll be there April 3rd
that's almost sold out Rohnert Park
California April 10th Las Vegas I'm
going to be there the 17th and 18th
April and also in August and then Brea
California lost I'll be the Brea
California April 30th to weekend's May
7th that weekend too and then the big
banger coming up dude is Atlantic City
Atlantic City New Jersey I'm gonna be at
the Borgata Hotel and Casino and we love
it there dude I stayed at the Showboat
casino to do army of death and that was
[ __ ] that that Hotel is absolutely
awful but I went to the Borgata to go
have sushi in with the cast and it was
great do it
might as well have been in Vegas so went
to Atlantic City there to do that and
now your boy done came up and going to
the Borgata Hotel so get your tickets
it's selling out it just went on sale so
don't sleep the good tickets are OMA or
gone maybe I don't know get some [ __ ]
tickets go to Crystal it calm here's
another thing all life rips stock is
back it's cuz of the stock it's back
dude we got the life rips tie-dye hoodie
you got the life ribs black hoodie in
all sizes and you got the life ripped
t-shirt in all sizes now for some reason
for some rates I put it on Instagram and
immediately you know they all sell out
in a day but immediately people are
commenting like what the [ __ ] it's
already sold out now those people they
don't got brains okay clear your cache
clear your cache a or whatever the [ __ ]
you call it because it's definitely okay
and it's definitely not sold out but
also bag so you can get tickets and go
your [ __ ] at Chris D'Elia calm go all
your [ __ ] not it's not something but
anyway it's really cool that I could you
know I think I don't
the levels are wrong and then I I say
the left side of the levels aren't as
good as the right side of the shits and
then I check with one fire one fire
legitimately said said to me today
before we started I don't think it's a
problem with that
I think you have I think have ear
problems and that was the most
disrespectful thing I've ever heard all
of 20/20 so far so it's all good but
that's you know that's legitimately what
happened so I got your problems already
and I'm not even 40
my dad says what so much and he's 72
sometimes my dad says so what so much
that he just gives up sometimes and I
could see his face just be like oh I'm
just not gonna hear that and that's
gonna be the thing I'll say something
like do you like spaghetti and he'll be
like I don't lay all he has no idea even
that I'm asking a question he's just
pretending to hear what I have to say
and thinks it's a statement all good
dude but I'm gonna do that too and I'm
probably gonna end up doing that when
I'm [ __ ] 42 because left ear already
gone my babies
so anyway I'm doing what would the [ __ ]
was I gonna say god damn life rips were
all back so go get that [ __ ] gonna sell
out and I also got an argument with my
opener last night he doesn't know
turns out it's a main segrand story you
can check it out for a few more hours
turns out he doesn't know what it means
when I say or when anybody he doesn't
know the phrase bull in a china shop now
that's the dumbest now I didn't know
there were levels of dumbness that went
that deep hello but here's a dumb shovel
you diggin what dude you don't know what
bull in a china shop means I said to him
you're like a bull bucking around and he
said well that's a good thing I said
yeah but you're like a bull in a china
shop and he said a china shop and I said
do you know what a china shop is and he
said yeah it's a shop and I said full of
and he said China you know he said China
things and I said hey man what's China
and he said glass dude he didn't know
what it was got mad blood levels rose
okay he hits the table so much when he
talks to it it drives me nuts man and I
got all the other guys on board with it
too
they understand that he hits the table
too much when we're talking when he's
talking he'll just be like talking and
hitting the table and [ __ ] and my elbow
is already on the table because I don't
need to be keep hitting them cuz here's
the other thing too if you're listening
to me great good for you if you're not
you don't get some hot lasagna you don't
get a conversational plate of hot
lasagna and that's on you because what I
say it's free right now I get paid to
speak so if you're not listening to me
that's on you all right so this guy's
[ __ ] so I don't so that's how I do it
you know it's like the whole mobster
thing it's like the loudest person in
the room his guy doesn't say [ __ ] at all
you know that's probably in every other
[ __ ] mob movie the loudest in the room
sometimes it's the most silent that's
definitely a line in some [ __ ]
student film you know and that that
somebody's that somebody's uncle says
and and so he's [ __ ] always hitting me
and touching me and hitting the table
and [ __ ] the guy so he so wishes he was
from New Jersey and he's from a place
that's even more New Jersey than New
Jersey and that's Florida uh so he was
doing all that [ __ ] and that was pissing
me off and I [ __ ] called him out on
and we were all laughing me and the
other guys were there Craig tonin mark
Hayes and anyway that's the [ __ ]
story from last night
found it do my coffee being closed the
[ __ ] down man so sad but life reps
they're not gonna stop me from having a
good time kickin it at a cafe that I
like and sipping some iced americano
dude I got one right here in my Batman
cup at a home but they're not gonna stop
me dude these people come up to me and
they're like aw man your coffee being
closed down what are you gonna do cuz
it's turning into a Starbucks bro
Starbucks tastes like the back of a
cow's mouth y'all know it found a
Starbucks though found a Starbucks that
I go to in the meantime and it's it's
it's fine
a cop pulled me over on the way there
the last time and it was the [ __ ] dude
because the cop pulled me over and I was
like please be young guy please be a
young guy please don't be 70 because if
he's 70 he doesn't know who I am
but if he's 35 there's a chance he'll
let me go and he comes up to me he says
hey man and I say hey man sorry and he
says oh it's all good are you the
comedian I said yeah he said I'm a big
fan I said I'll cool he said well I'm
can I get your license and registration
I gave it to him he said all right man
well don't worry about it and I was like
[ __ ] in kept on rolling dude when a cop
doesn't give you a ticket you feel like
[ __ ] DJ Khaled you're just like
another one anyway
uh yeah dude but News News guess what
guess who's a [ __ ] real daddy now I
had my baby boy everything is completely
healthy and everything is great and I'm
in love I'm in love with this boy do you
understand that do you understand how
somebody could just come out all of a
sudden you love them like you knew him
15 years do you understand that do you
understand you can just love somebody
immediately bro I'll hold him I would
hold him if my back hurts and it does
hurt and I still hold him he shits I
check it with my hand boom around back I
don't need to open it up I don't give a
[ __ ] if I got [ __ ] on the hand I go wash
it that shit's from me anyway dude I
love him so much
immediately and I'll hold him and I'll
[ __ ] kiss his nose it's so great
Wow do you know what it's like the
experience when you have a baby wow I
can't believe I'm saying this right now
but do you know what it's like the only
way I can describe it cuz everyone
describes it and you're like oh really I
guess I don't know what it's like cool
you know if you don't have a baby a lot
of you guys have babies out there a lot
of you guys don't have babies and that's
fine and a lot of guys will have babies
in here like I wonder what it's like
let me ask let me let me hit let me list
let me listen you know here's a hot
plate of [ __ ] conversational lasagna
you might like everything in life you
can compare to something else in your
life everything from a really obvious
one like if you play football and you
play baseball before you like there's a
little bit like baseball I'm running
around trying to catch a ball too living
in an apartment there's a little bit
like camping you can draw from it you
know if you were an alien that came down
to the world and you were like oh some
people camp and live outside and some
people live in apartments you wouldn't
think it was much different you'd be
like this is just how they reside do you
know what I'm saying but having a baby
is not comparable to anything else
there's not something you can draw from
in your bank of experiences when that
person enters the room you know you just
immediately sit back and you are you
know what you're doing you're pondering
dude you're just thinking and you're
barely thinking though you got like a
little bit of a blip boop boop that's
you thinking you're like I get and then
you're just looking at the baby and
you're stupefied cuz you're thinking
because you're live but you're not
really thinking of actual things you
know you've got this worldly [ __ ]
it's like this sunrise is happening
inside of your head and you're holding
your baby and you love him it's not even
love it's the next thing it's like when
you when you go to the East Coast if you
learn about attics you know like oh we
don't have those out west oh but that's
the [ __ ] love up there
you got [ __ ] higher you go back to you
could be from the west coast you go back
to the east coast you're like oh you got
another floor on top of the top floor
that shit's where your baby is in the
Attic that's love
and then just chill him with him in a
rocking chair man it's so beautiful man
and it's awesome the youngest man alive
finally has somebody younger than him
and I love it I'm not even 40 how are
young he's beautiful too man he sleeps
about [ __ ] 26 hours a day and what is
that surround sound noise that babies
make - it's like it doesn't come from
their mouth what is going on it's like
all of a sudden you have headphones on
and you just hear you're like where's
that coming from
do you know what I'm saying a baby will
just be chilling his mouth would be
closed and they'll be like and you're
like how did you make that noise [ __ ]
hey dude how'd you make that noise oh
dude a baby can make a noise with their
mouth closed and make it sound like an
open mouth noise babies are [ __ ]
crazy and their mouth is closed to do it
it wasn't coming from hey baby
where's that coming from but he was good
he was a he's a little bit he was six
pounds nine ounces and he [ __ ] broke
he's drinking milk you know from the
titty I don't like how to I don't know
how to say I don't like breastfeeding
and this [ __ ] you're supposed to
you're supposed to go you you're born
and I don't know if you know this I
didn't know this but you're born and
then you lose the weight and then you're
supposed to be back to your regular
weight in two in two weeks so if you're
6.9 or whatever the [ __ ] then you lose
the weight and then in two weeks you're
6.9 again this [ __ ] in five days
gained
four ounces he's a fatty you just keeps
drinking that teddy milk but he loves it
do it he loves it whatever we're gonna
do man I think he's gonna have a good
body when he gets older I think it's
gonna be jacked cuz we have good bodies
man this dude's gonna take the best of
both shits you know you're gonna be like
oh we thought daliyah the dad had
[ __ ] mountains on his on his back we
thought they filmed Lord of the Rings on
his back bro this baby [ __ ] a trilogy
this guy's got a whole series they're
doing a TV show on his back but yeah
it's a great bonding experience too
if you're if you're with with with your
whoever you're doing it with your wife
your girlfriend whatever it is it's just
amazing it's just weird and then also I
cried for [ __ ] three days straight
straight up cried when he came out never
stop put him skin-to-skin cuz I do that
I saw the rock do it on Instagram but I
would have done it anyway and I put it
on I didn't copy the rock but I put the
baby on the on my on my chest and it was
so a [ __ ] sorry I don't mean to go on
about as a comedy podcast but dude [ __ ]
y'all this baby's this [ __ ] and also
he's cute and I think that you know
sometimes I think your baby is so cute
no matter what I think also taking
myself out of it if I looked at the baby
like that's a good one aesthetically
pleasing but I put him on I put him on
my my chest and it was and I started
crying again oh man there was one time
where in the middle of the pregnancy the
nurse was like sometimes the baby's
heart rate drops and I got to hit this
button and a lot of doctors come in and
don't be alarmed it's very common but it
is very overwhelming and don't don't
worry about it I got to hit the thing I
got to hit this button it's the button
to let them all come in and when they
come in there's gonna be like 25 of them
and they all do different things so it's
an important time when I hit this button
and I don't know what's wrong exactly so
all these doctors come in and we all try
to figure it out and
and that's what happens and I was like
okay okay I hope you don't have to hit
the button but if you do okay and and
they were like doing it and they were
like okay and something happened and I
was like I didn't know what was going on
and I could see the nurses face and she
got not worried but concerned and she's
like okay a lot of doctors are coming in
so the [ __ ] went down the [ __ ] happened
the heart rate wise is everything okay
and they said the heart rate dipped a
little bit we got some doctors come in
dude
do you know do you know how many doctors
come in okay first of all they put
oxygen on my girl my girls looking at me
like is it okay and your boy doesn't
know because I'm a comedian I'm the only
person in that room that doesn't make
any difference
you got nurses you got doctors you got
[ __ ] doulas by the way what's that
mean is that a midwife I don't know I
don't even know the Midwife is I barely
know what a wife is all right
and so they hit the button dude and all
these [ __ ] come in my girl
looks at me like is it okay and I'm like
mister and charge always in charge of
everything and I'm um I'm like hey for
the first time I think and so many
doctors came in dude it was a joke it
was like one of those [ __ ] Japanese
subways where they were just like put we
need more doctors in there were dug by
outside just putting pushing jump
running and jumping in cuz they couldn't
fit here I come
and then dude they kept coming and dude
it was like the [ __ ] the the Coolio
video where all the people kept coming
out of the trunk it was like that I was
like come on dude it was absolutely
ridiculous it was like this there's a
button in this happen
[Music]
doctors came in with their stethoscopes
Fantastic Voyage heart rates dropping
drippity drop her trace tripity tripity
drop in come on y'all let's start to cry
Wow it's too [ __ ] overwhelming come
alone
the hearts drippity drop in by remedy by
hopefully they [ __ ] kid survives and
I'm just like Jesus Christ hi I'm doctor
dude and the doctors were so young they
could be friends with the baby that came
out the doctors were so young at cedar
cyanide they were literally they look
like DJs they just came out and they
were just like hi I'm doctor you could
just call me Steve actually I'm not even
done with my [ __ ] my name is Steve just
called me Steve I'm gonna help out I may
be I swear to God what are you oh I'm
the DJ I didn't know if they needed did
they need a I could play something well
what are you gonna play are you [ __ ]
kidding me
[Music]
wow I haven't heard that a long time
a doctor came in on a [ __ ] bicycle
and [ __ ]
I want one came in on the unicycle you
need me oh no no we don't okay just back
to the way out he came in and then it
all turned out to be okay the heart rate
went back up and all the doctors left
and then I got lonely they all [ __ ]
left dude there were so many of them I
swear to God when they hit that button
get ready because you cry if you don't
cry when 25 doctors come in a room
you're a [ __ ] you're a rock you're a
piece of [ __ ] you're the Undertaker dude
if you don't cry when 20 doctors working
I don't care if it's a [ __ ] party a
doctor's party it's so overwhelming I
never cried in my life because something
is overwhelming and there was too much
[ __ ] going on that my eyes just went hmm
[ __ ] it whoa
those are the tears I never cried
because of overwhelm it what am i Huff
hey dude what am i some [ __ ] no way
dude I'm the man and I was overwhelmed
and I cried remember the Herman Cain
commercial - who's that guy dude you got
a [ __ ] send it to me or whatever the
[ __ ] anyway dude I love my son
everything is awesome he's six days old
and y'all could go [ __ ] yourself he's so
dope he made so many doctors come in the
room how many [ __ ] doctors is your
boy may come into the room
[Music]
come along and ride on a fantastic
voyage come along and ride on a
fantastic voyage fantastic voyage that's
crazy that that's a hip hop song it's
such a white thing to say all right here
we go babies we got some ads kaptara if
you work for a small business or have a
side gig you probably need to find
software though yayoi but you also have
other things to do things you'd probably
rather be doing well you can cut to the
chase with kaptara
the website millions of people use
monthly to find software for their team
or business they simplified the software
search into a few steps
it starts with using their free
resources and guides to pinpoint the
problem and identify the software
features you need then you can filter
options to find the right software for
your industry they have over 700
specific categories of software to
understand that that's so many and you
can even compare them side-by-side and
save your favourites to a shortlist it's
really cool I've seen it I tried it with
baking and you can do that you can do a
little read everything pick something so
with they have a free in-depth software
guides and tools plus over 1 million
reviews from real users kaptara will
give you access to everything you need
to know before you buy so you could
spend less time trying to find your
software and more time doing what you
love
visit kaptara comm / congrats for free
today to find the software tools you
need for your business kaptara comm /
Congrats kaptara that's Capt R sorry
Capt e RR a.com slash Congrats let me
say that again that's Capt e RR a.com
slash Congrats kaptara software
selection simplified manscaped breaking
news this is important this is this
important PSA is brought to you by
manscape comm this is your well they're
they told me to say this so this is your
pubic service announcement the manscaped
engineering team spent 18 months
perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer
created and you can say that on an ad
and just released the new and improved
lawnmower 3000 I'm sorry it's not called
that it's um lawn mower 3.0 but you
might as well be 3000 because you might
as well be living in the year 3000 the
way you could do this without nicking
your balls back there third-generation
trimmer features of cutting edge ceramic
blade to prevent manscaping accident man
I've been using this and it's awesome no
cuts dude I've got as many cuts as I do
dunce
look I've been talking about man skate
for a while now manscape products made
personal grooming something I actually
care about and now when I take off my
pants my girl looks like the wee-bey
mean when I tell you this is premium I
mean Premium the battery will last up to
90 minutes so you could take a longer
shave maybe you're a really hairy guy
you got to get the inside of your legs
to a little bit go ahead get 20% off
free shipping with the code congrats at
manscape calm and as always your balls
will thank you the made me say that to
get 20% off and free shipping with no
code congrats at manscape comm that's
20% off with Free Shipping at manscape
calm and use the code congrats dude
where's that Herman Cain thing in my
notes
nice one higher even though he said I
have ear problems one [ __ ] higher one
[ __ ] higher Herman Cain first of all
the guy's name Herman Cain is the most
I'll tell on you name I've ever heard in
my life
aw come on Herman don't tell on me
gotta why my last name's cane and my
first name is Herman this was the you
know Pro Herman Cain ad in 2012 and it
went viral back then but god damn dude
it's so funny this guy who's this guy on
it oh he says it I'm a player
our clock here okay I mean the shot is
so vignette it it's hilarious like it's
it's blurt which means it's blurry on
the outside like to make it seem
I don't know cooler marc bloch here at
don't be on camera marc bloch here okay
this guy [ __ ] in his life has said
this so many times well nine out of ten
that's how many thing he's said that so
many times in his life
marc bloch here nine out of ten people
think that you know first of all the
music streets of rage since the the
[ __ ] sound design dude rock block
here where did they film this in an
[ __ ] Marc Bach hair stinks like [ __ ]
we're shooting this in an [ __ ]
this way to the end then marc bloch here
since taking this sweet old time since
january marc bloch who are you since
January I've had the privilege of being
the chief of staff to Herman Cain and
the chief operating officer of the
friends are they're zooming in so far it
might as well be a [ __ ] sonogram of
his brain tomorrow tomorrow say all the
syllables dude I've never seen something
that they only did one take on and then
Marc Bloch was like I'm doing one
they're like can we please get it again
and he said why like doesn't get how
things are filmed well because you know
if you do another one we could cut it
together and he's but just use the one
shot
and they'd be like well it's just better
to have safety nine out of ten people
will disagree with you and then walks
away dude
it seems in so far
and the chief operating officer the
friends are in hurricane tomorrow of the
wot dude 'some mumbling and the chief
operating officer of the friends owner
McCain the chief I read my officer of
the Friends of McCain is he saying
friends of McCain marc bloch here come
on dude they're the friends earner
McCain say to get her McCain he said
friends at her McCain I swear to god he
says friends at her name McCain braiding
officer of the friends earner McCain
under McCain gotta be friends under
McCain whatever he's saying say it again
marc bloch marc bloch here he's gonna
mumble through this Earl it's one day
closer to the White House I really
believe that Herman Cain will put United
back in he goes like this he goes like
this United back he goes like that
United like he's trying to [ __ ]
rupture his desk Erica and if I didn't
believe that I wouldn't be her we've run
a campaign like nobody's ever seen but
then America has never seen a candidate
like Herman Cain hey we need you to get
involved because together we could do
this we could take this country back
he's smoking because he's badass dude
because that's the [ __ ] kind of
grassroots [ __ ] you do around here
man
Herman Cain Wow bro he's smoking smoking
is so bad for you marc bloch don't you
know that
what are you also what are you doing bro
you're not [ __ ] 15 anti-establishment
you're literally a politician and you're
60 I think they're singing in this
together we can do this we can take this
country smoking
Wow is this [ __ ]
they got [ __ ] with only a blazer on
Herman Cain creepy a smile of all time
also why is he in front of apartment
blinds Wow
dude one buys [ __ ] round and burning
mark block
dude he's he's straight up in front of
apartment blinds Herman Cain for real
he's in those shitty-ass apartment
blinds that come when you [ __ ] rent a
room for like six hundred dollars a
month that's where they shot it
that's insane wow it's so funny man
mark block her a [ __ ] rooster [ __ ]
block here I'll Park the [ __ ] here
that's what he says dude [ __ ] mark talk
here
or park here wow dude just so great look
at the comments watching this years
later still hilarious dude why are there
such close-ups of both of them it's like
this yet Herman Cain Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing marc bloch here our
frontrunner McCain Bing so drunk smoked
in it dude put it out wow dude I just
can't believe these [ __ ] sat a
touch I can't believe anybody thinks
anything is a good idea like that oh
dude there was a [ __ ] thing on
Instagram holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it was so
funny I sent it let me see if I can find
it bro I gotta send this to you and we
got to put it on the thing
we got to put it on the thing man where
is it hold on let me find this you guys
it's worth it just wait marc bloch here
just wait block here dude I got to send
it to you I'm gonna send it to you right
now and we're gonna put it on the thing
it's on your it's in your dams it's
called the PSO underscore right dude I
don't even know how to tell you what's
happening I guess I'm gonna put it it
how the PSO right makes you feel release
tension in your body with one of the
best massage tools on the market your
patented design allows you to reach
almost every muscle in your body get
you're safe okay so this guy is
squatting no he's he's what do you call
it not squatting what'd he call that
clean clue jerkin clean what are the
[ __ ] the bait weights in the base of it
and I wrote under it hard is the most
horrible ad I've ever seen I wish people
people these are the comments watching
this ad I have no idea what the product
is is this a barbell stand some of the
worst advertisement what am I even
looking at won't buy some garbage if I
don't know what the garbage is for what
the hell am i watching you're joking
right looks like his joints will be
non-existent thirty years who's in
charge of your marketing this is great
just PSO you know need a strong not I
don't know with them those are not very
strange way of advertising it I don't
understand what this ad is for it looks
unsafe I'm so confused by this ad this
is these are all the comments do it this
is the worst marketing recorded or
something we can put it on the thing
it's I don't even know what it's for do
you babies anyway
bark bark air hmmm in game I just uh I
have a question and this is a sincere
question no hate no nothing cuz the
music say what you want feel like it
that's great certainly sounds nice how
come every time I open up anything my
phone my computer my closet or my
[ __ ] zipper I have to hear I have to
read a headline about how how amazing
lizzo looks why do I have to always read
that that's my question to put out there
why do I have to always read Liz Oh was
on the carpet of the Vietnamese VMAs and
looked and slayed she's a
Queen look at how she killed her outfit
and then I got a look and she's wearing
literally a Hershey's bar she wore a
dress that said Hershey's on it the
other day and everyone's like and she
absolutely killed it Hey Dude know how
she did end and that's just a regular
free song I didn't put out on iTunes
dude you don't look good like that why
are we pretending I know why I know why
I know why we're saying it I know why
we're saying it because she's overweight
and because there's been so much fat
shaming in the world that now we got a
backtrack in the pendulum swing too far
the other way and now there has to be
headlines every day about how [ __ ]
goddamn sexy
Liz ohh looks but hey what about this
her music what about that what about how
you're making it so looks are the most
important thing what about that what
about that you superficial [ __ ] who
cares if who cares how she looks then
who cares how she looks right if who
cares that she's a little overweight
then who cares how she looks why do we
have to [ __ ] keep talking about how
bangin she looks who cares
who [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] I don't care
what weight she is if she's happy and
killing it on stage what the [ __ ] do I
care
I don't give a [ __ ] but but every time I
open she looks banging in that [ __ ]
well does she beware tinfoil people be
like Lizzie Lizzie showed up boy did she
slay in some tinfoil Hey no you look
like The Tin Man
it's embarrassing you're embarrassing
yourself bloggers I hope she knows and
she's just taking the piss and you guys
just don't even understand her levels
hey also remember when she did the thing
at the basketball game and she just
showed up with her [ __ ] out and
everyone was like she slayed her [ __ ]
[ __ ] was out dude her [ __ ] [ __ ]
was out and we had to pretend like she
slayed dude if my [ __ ] was out
[Music]
my whole [ __ ] might my ass in front
of apartment blinds just pivoting and
then I open up and my [ __ ] opens up
and I just go new man on a Minnesota
Vikings she showed up wearing a
Hershey's [ __ ] milk chocolate wrapper
hey he didn't slay you look like
chocolate I mean dude why do we pretend
she slay dude if [ __ ] Halle Berry
showed up like that you roast her
rightfully so it's hilarious what this
world has come to oh she got that chunk
huh
look at that ass Jesus look at what
everyone says pretty I don't know
Oh what is she doing hey you got grandma
hey guy grandma anyone that does that is
a [ __ ] man these chicks you know
they'll be on the four voices [ __ ] no
man on the Venice onna biking's
down down the down--get Gong down down
anybody who does that in the middle of
song I'm armed I hate when people say
this but I'm here for it do it cuz you
feel it's so dope down Gong Gong Gong
Gong Gong that's the [ __ ] dude I love it
put on a regular dress umm yeah I love
it dude
uh anyway I'll [ __ ] make an album and
I'll show up in a Hershey's outfit
imagine if I made an album and my voice
was the [ __ ] and I was killing it and
then I showed up in a [ __ ] Hershey's
outfit how they would drag me down Ganga
gown even if I did down Gong Gong Gong
Gong Gong Gong Gong no man on the
Minnesota Vikings I love it I love this
movement
whatever you do is right girls whatever
you do is right girls I had a guy saw a
guy with his [ __ ] with a believe all
women shirt the other day and I
literally just thought about how like my
ex would lie to me a lot down Gong Gong
Gong Gong Gong no man on the Minnesota
Vikings dude hey man really believe all
women my girl cheated on me lots dong
Gong Gong Gong Gong Gong Gong Gong
cancel me what the [ __ ] do I care you
know I love it I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
cape with a [ __ ] huge green collar
and then y'all could kiss my [ __ ] ass
me and my son just kissing each other
[Music]
I'm free dude that's the thing that's
why you listen to this podcast that's
what I realized right now while you
listen this podcast because I'm free I'm
[ __ ] free man and yeah there's haters
out there does people say you can't say
that you can't say that and NPR
sure you could learn a lot and you don't
learn [ __ ] from this podcast except for
the very important stuff and you listen
because I'm free dude I'm that like 9th
guy they didn't film in [ __ ] One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest
that they cut out on the on the on the
on the on the floor on the car that's on
the cutting-room floor that's like you
know what I'm he's talkin to ya that's
the guy that's talkin about [ __ ] no
dents and how life rips and calling
everybody a CUDA and he keeps going down
gonk gonk down going down down and
showing everybody their [ __ ] dude
[Music]
it's a soft blue apron
look guys health is personal but no
matter what it looks like it should
taste good that's why blue apron wants
to help you create a mean a mealtime
routine that works for you one that's
not centered around fads or diets but an
enjoyable long term approach to eating
create a personalized plan that works
for you with blue aprons ever-changing
mix of plant forward vegetarian
carb-conscious mediterranean diabetes
friendly
ww approved and 500 calorie or less
options you choose from a variety of
chef's designed ready to cook meals and
get perfectly portioned fresh
ingredients all delivered straight to
your door busy week traveling blue apron
is flexible man they'll drop it off when
you want only deliveries for the weeks
that work for you at the beginning of a
new year is a great time to reevaluate
your lifestyle you know what I'm talking
about
a piggy blue apron believe is a healthy
lifestyle starch a balanced starts with
a balanced relationship with food
knowing exactly what goes into each meal
man stop going to McDonald's and stuff
McDonald's stop going to McDonald's best
of all blue apron helps me disconnect
from my phone discover my inner chef and
learn new recipes and techniques they
have seared steak with roasted broccoli
YUM
mushroom and kill gnocchi YUM beyond
beef and quinoa enchiladas a young
eating doesn't have to be about
deprivation don't compromise on flavor
or suffer through boring meals embrace
whole ingredients and eat with all your
senses check out this week's menu and
get $60 off when you visit blue apron
calm / Congrats that's blue apron calm /
Congrats blue apron feed your soul Gong
Gong Gong the Gong Gong Gong Gong better
help listen guys is there something
interfering with your happiness or is
preventing you from achieving your goals
I know that I've had that in my life
whether it's sleep deprivation or stress
sometimes anxiety really clogs me up you
know but better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 24 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help line it is professional
counseling done securely online
there's a broad range of expertise in
better helps counselor network which may
not be locally available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor it's really great and you know
a lot of people need this you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video hour phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room huh
about that plus you can even chat in
text with your therapist between say
sessions better help visit better help
calm / Congrats adjoined over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm /
Congrats uh yeah so I want to say I want
to thank my community friends dude it's
so cool to have a community of friends
like I feel so lucky to be a part of
something like my comedian friends like
it's just so cool I was over Sebastian's
house the other day so banished
Sebastian Maniscalco and Bobbie Lee was
there Bryan Callen was there Whitney
Cummings was there a lot of you know a
lot of people there and it was just cool
to be feel like a part of something Bill
burr was there and it was just nice how
genuinely happy everybody was and happy
for each other we were laughing having a
good time and it's just so cool to have
that man like a community of friends
that gives you [ __ ] about you and I
don't you know I'm not just talking
about my community or friends in with my
comedian friends I'm talking about I got
all the other people I got friends from
high school that I still talked to one
or two and I got other friends that I
just have out here in LA and [ __ ] and
it's just really [ __ ] cool man to
have that support from each other and
for people to give a [ __ ] like I care
about my friends I care about what
happens to them and I care I like that
they care about what happens to me man
and I feel very fortunate and all I'm
saying is I feel fortunate and thank you
to my friends and thank you to the world
for letting me have that [ __ ] man it's
so cool dude now if you could just stop
talking about how great [ __ ]
how great Blizzard's dresses are that'll
be amazing everybody you guys seen this
Dwyane Wade thing where his I guess his
son that it was a son and then now is
going by xiah and so it's Dwyane Wade's
daughter and Dwyane Wade has been really
cool about putting it out there and
letting his son his I guess it used to
be a I don't know how to say it just
don't cancel me and you know it's his
daughter and he decided to be known as a
woman so Dwyane Wade and Gabrielle Union
have been really cool and letting their
son do that you know I look I don't know
the ins and outs of it I don't I never
met the family but I just if if it's
something that the 12 14 whatever were
year old is like yeah I want to be a
girl so that's what I might be a man
change my name is aya twelve-year-old
child it's cool that the kid you know it
came out and it's cool that the parents
are being supportive this is on
Billboard but following Dwyane Wade
support for his twelve-year-old child
desire coming out as a transgender girl
the lgbtq+ community rejoice and praise
the basketball stars acceptance and
parenting and it's just weird that like
how much the hip hop community and
sports community doesn't accept this you
know cuz like here's the deal did if my
son is 13 and he's like yo I like
dresses I want to wear that [ __ ] I don't
really care if you want to do that do
that you know and if you grow out of it
then you grow out of it if it's a phase
okay and if it's not okay and if you
have a son and a daughter that is
transgender then and you know look if I
think of a SIF a five-year-old as I cut
my [ __ ] dick off maybe you have a
word with them and be like well you know
when you're older you cut your dick off
but that's not what's happening here
because gender and sex is
different and young thug took to Twitter
on Tuesday February 18th all I want to
say to Dwayne's son is God don't make
mistakes but hey lifted yourself first
of all
young thug you wear dresses on your
album cover so what are you saying
second of all what the [ __ ] do you have
to do with Dwayne Wade's family that's
the [ __ ] that bothers me so much look I
don't even care if I don't believe in
what you're doing which you know it
sounds like what Dwayne Wade is doing is
trying to be a [ __ ] stand-up
fotheringay by owners trying to be a
stand-up mother but when someone tries
to and I thought this before I had a kid
when someone tries to intervene and tell
someone else had a parent or do what
their or this is what you should do
that's so [ __ ] you know how annoying
it is to get advice at all in any realm
when you're at the gym and someone's
like you know you got to do this to make
dick bro shut the [ __ ] up let me pull it
let me [ __ ] my back up the way I'm gonna
do it I'm me but you're gonna [ __ ]
tell someone had a parent what the [ __ ]
does young thug give a [ __ ] about the
way a basketball guy raises his family
that's some true [ __ ] [ __ ] who gives
a [ __ ] dude why do you care in the whole
rap game I don't give a [ __ ] if you
don't give a [ __ ] why the hell are you
thinking about Dwayne Wayans daughter
family at all
also you wear pigtails k also you wear
dresses k I mean that's a [ __ ]
grenade
that drives me nuts dude let the [ __ ]
parent parent the way they're gonna
parent the kids gonna be well adjunct
pillows you know what dude
who's that Busey said some [ __ ] to which
I don't even know who he is I don't know
if that's showing my age or if the guy I
think he's actually an older rapper
Busey looks like he's oh it looks like
he's 50 Busey Dwyane Wade let me look
this up Busey goes on rant about Dwayne
Wade supporting his let's look at this
of course it's gonna be a [ __ ] guy
talking about her first would this is
Breakfast Club I don't want to see this
I want to see the thing how can when you
click on something boozy the the the the
it's it's always the first one isn't
always the thing that the guys saying
it's like last Tuesday da data it's like
dude look boozy going in on wait here we
go here we go no you don't aren't you a
rapper
the way you've gone too [ __ ] far now
that is a male a way of your way its way
up they don't even know they don't even
know what they next meal gonna be they
don't they don't have [ __ ] figured out
chance he might meet a woman anything
has 16 and fall in love with him okay
but his big be gone Idol they're not
cutting the kids dick off why why is he
acting like this the kids put a dress on
don't like bro for real if you're gonna
be gay let him be gay but don't cut
who's carding his dick off like don't
address him as a woman dog he's 12 years
old he don't he's not he's not up there
yet
he hasn't made his final decision
don't cut his [ __ ] dick off the way
way bro you [ __ ] tripping dog really
insightful really insightful well so
we're here live Andy then we are with
the reports Dwyane Wade is tripping do
you have anything else you want to say
well the problem is is that Dwyane Wade
is tripping and the only thing really
problem with the only real problem
Dwyane Wade has is how he spells his
first name it should be do we Ann back
to you know Dwayne we may are tripping
man you know they are what else he also
said this he doubled down on it always
with this [ __ ] these rappers live in
mansions you know you see me do
something going you're [ __ ] a hot tub
so annoying I mean so rocketed to the
next level
bro you're just commenting badly on
something
y'all don't love what I say do some well
there's actually a lot of steps we can
take in between
how exhausting would it be to be a guy
like this you know what I mean or just
to even be around a guy like this [ __ ]
some [ __ ] we step in [ __ ] yeah yeah
[ __ ] out of God's working out I'm
finding out I'm gonna throw some [ __ ]
yeah he's getting hung up in the closet
next to your clothes [ __ ] make me talk
my [ __ ] yeah yeah that's good point you
can kill someone don't cut his dick off
and he thought agreed me do something
I'll kill you ah sir drastic you want me
to [ __ ] big if you were born in age
what [ __ ] I see your deal with to a
Tupac and Biggie to that call again
there lizardy record game yeah Wow he's
dressed like a nine year old multi y'all
[ __ ] not yeah I'm finna top some old
gangsta is she okay we're ready
this is great look at nice just looking
at it okay let's get this talking [ __ ]
I'm straight I mean who know nothing's
happening and this guy's so mad be some
black tea big dogs daily be Chinese
statments Abu Zubaydah today say it's
time what no it's so funny dude these
people in the comments somebody just
right stop playing with us punks nothing
is happening like nothing is happening
in these guys like y'all [ __ ]
better stop okay
imagine being a [ __ ] business meeting
with this guy you're just like I don't
know okay look we're not trying to [ __ ]
with you so you're like an album where
[Music]
they're so mad
they're pretend mad they're diving
laughs this is the worst in my I'm a
[ __ ] ball yay
what is he talking about yay don't where
I'm raising man believe it I don't go
I'm not going forward
I'm not going forward hey how many kids
does Busey have I want to know that can
you find that out I'm not going he's not
going well he's whatever it is he's not
going for it I'll tell you that much
how many boot kids does Busey have more
children oh wow oh [ __ ] go up go up go
up oh my god Ivy ray what one two three
four five six seven kids how old is he
go down 37 years ago seven kids also
he's younger than me dude he looks 50
that's not like how black guys don't
they don't look old until one day he got
he had I didn't he hit that day early
he's like them that's so weird
oh he's five six hey man you're not
gonna do [ __ ] you know imagine him in a
fight with Dwayne Wade Dwayne Wade would
literally hold him down in just [ __ ] on
him Busey badass you know what's he
would rapper singer songwriter record
producer record executive actor actor
this is just so great Busey it this
guy's a [ __ ] dork what a dork dude
look at this lil boosie's your cousin
how I mean he does he take care of all
his kids seven kids that's hard to take
care of and this guy's like don't cut
your dick off man
I mean having seven kids
I know [ __ ] Mormons with seven kids
they don't pay attention all of them so
a rapper
oh man God
let's do Twitter questions I want to
talk this this [ __ ] boozy I do it you
know boozy five six dude that's
hilarious that he's five six talking
like that god these guys need to get
knocked the [ __ ] out sometimes you know
I'll do some bro
it'd be great it'd be great if it killed
me because I talk like this oh this is
great you guys are finally understanding
what's a [ __ ] means the term from Tom
Hallberg how [ __ ] is it to sit down on
the edge of the pool and to lower down
in yes so [ __ ] he writes it's not a hot
tub it's a I mean even it's even [ __ ]
to do in a hot tub yeah it's so [ __ ]
just jump in that's a good one dude
you're right how [ __ ] is it - this is
Bob Joseph Joseph Hannon how [ __ ] is it
to dab the corner of a napkin in a glass
of water wipers are spot off your shirt
oh that's [ __ ] yeah well the thing
about the B&S [ __ ] is you can do
anything knots a [ __ ] anything you can
do in a nuts a [ __ ] way but there are
things that just lend itself to be an
esse [ __ ] like if you dab it if you're
just doing it like this that's a [ __ ]
but if you just grab it you're just like
[ __ ] get this [ __ ] thing out it's
not so [ __ ] but yeah so there's like a
sliding scale if you're gonna lower
yourself into a pool it's really hard to
do that not submit we submit wise hey
Chris Lee this is Lexus Carrera hey
Chris Lee I'm app I'm episode 8 yes I'm
behind a note you should talk games I'll
have you know cards against humanity' is
a great game oh you know what Lexus oh
can you hear me smile oh hey dude cards
against
humanity you know spry not that good but
let's say it is good cuz lots of people
play up you're still a [ __ ] dork and
that's all good
own it I'm a dork about certain things
but I don't play cards against humanity'
uh because I just don't want to play
games man I [ __ ] hate games i when
people are talking having a good time
and then somebody comes in they're just
like wanna play taboo I'm just like all
right bro I'm out man I'm gonna start
smoking this is just [ __ ] I'm
talking about I'm gonna go kiss my son
dude hold him and look at his eyes feels
good it's so weird to be in love this
[ __ ] little boy love this little boy
my son and love of them all right you
guys that's it you can text me at eight
one eight two three nine seventy eighty
seven the merch is up life rips all
restocked it'll be gone tomorrow so go
get your [ __ ] if you want where remember
when you do get it where I'm at other
comedians shows and sit in the first few
rows so they have to see that [ __ ]
because we don't play no [ __ ] games
bro you go to a Brooke crisis show you
put on that live rip shirt or the nose
don't sure that's it remember get your
tickets at West Palm Beach
Robinson bill Mississippi Rohnert Park
California Brea and Atlantic City the
big one
Atlantic City let's do this is my
hometown New Jersey my home state New
Jersey so let's do it thanks for
listening guys all right see you
[Music]